taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
today time for t-a-s-t-e buds
so this is a this is a good battle today
you know this is one this has been
circling for a while I think because we
wanted to find uh I love whipped cream
I love it it's in my top it's in my top
I gotta tell you you like had to find
someone to to bat look we had to find
something to battle it with and then you
brought up chocolate syrup
which is fine but I feel like how dare
you well what you have on your side is
that it's chocolate and we know
especially from the big live episode of
the two Titans pizza versus chocolate
that chocolate is no joke chocolate got
pounded pretty good in that episode
I remember you you won by a pretty
decent margin uh yeah yeah I think but
you know that also chocolate has
consecutively lost on this show it is
lost to vanilla
right and I think it was I think it just
barely beat strawberry milk like
chocolate milk strawberry milk chocolate
milk I was like this is gonna you think
so well here's the thing I think you
have that on your side but I think this
one I imagine you're going down
uh I don't know I'm very curious I let
me start by saying
I think
should we just do the chant I mean like
are we going right go for it all right
let's go ready yeah time two
b-a-t-t-l-e butts I think whipped cream
could be the biggest waste of a food
product ever that's what you stand alone
on that island uh I gotta tell you as a
kid
I remember my mom when I was growing up
she loved whipped cream she loved it she
was one of these squirt the mouth
you know
one of these you know this this grassy
Odd as uh Cooper you should say the uh
R.I.P R.I.P Pat Cooper um
I
you know I I remember seeing it
I remember initially thinking it was
more ice cream on top of the ice cream
sure it wasn't I was disappointed then I
thought it was like icing
it wasn't I was disappointed when I
finally tasted it I remember just being
like this taste to me
almost like nothing like it's one of the
few Foods next to like Wafers where
you're like I can literally taste the
air in the food wow I don't have that
experience at all I I think no one has
that experience
it's whipped cream it's the Golden Goose
it's the topper of everything I can it's
it's way more versatile I mean let me
start with this what are you applying
chocolate syrup to other than ice cream
no babe chocolate milk okay I mean these
are two godsend dude
so then if you're saying that then
you're really putting up chocolate milk
against whipped cream in a way yeah but
I won't do that I'm just I know but I'm
just saying that might be people's
mentality so then you might have a
bigger way bigger chance than you
thought I might get beat up now
chocolate syrup
you these are these are look you the one
great Advantage you have right now is
that whipped cream is something that you
take a pop of
like solo that is on that's unreal yeah
I mean we've I mean first of all ready
Whip or the equivalent you know I'm not
talking about Cool Whip really no I love
Cool Whip Cool Whip is what I always
wanted whipped cream to taste like and
it doesn't taste yeah I mean I guess you
could this is also I mean fresh whipped
cream is one of the best things ever
made yeah that's and that's I
we should have specified because I feel
like
God damn it I love them both but I'm
just saying I love it I love it you're
using chocolate syrup in in ice on the
top of ice cream and to make a chocolate
milk my point is this if you said to me
we're going to a German restaurant
and they make homemade strudel
Inglorious Style
and a guy's gonna come to the table with
real whipped cream to put on top of it
there's no way I'm not jumping on that
sure I think the the drop off though
from that to what most whipped cream is
which is the air fueled sure
I I wonder if we should have specified
but it doesn't matter it's too late now
the the
I'm speaking basically to the
Americanized whipped cream it comes in a
can you squirt it in your mouth the
mouth squirt you can't that's it like
you're that's a huge I can't argue that
but what I will argue is
when you pull out ice cream let's call
it a cookies and cream let's call it a a
chocolate it's called a mint chocolate
chip it's called a chocolate chip let's
call it a cookie dough and then somebody
goes oh oh you know what I have
and they pull that Hershey's Chocolate
Syrup out of the cabinet you're like
so you also have hot fudge on yourself
it is that odd is that hot fudge
equivalent
no hot fudge is different okay hot fudge
is hot fudge they don't think that
either I mean I don't think they do I
think hot fudge the only thing you can
use hot fudge for is ice cream
chocolate syrup is a condiment like
whipped cream that can go on different
things I've seen people squirt chocolate
syrup shake or like they'll put on pie
sometimes or whatever like I don't do
that you know they put on a lot Hershey
pie like they'll you know like their
chocolate pie they'll drizzle it like
you know it's what whipped cream it's
the same use as whipped cream except for
you know you get I get the milk thing
and you get the pop of the mouth thing
um but I got to tell you somebody pulls
that bottle of the Hershey sear about
and you're like this ice cream just
jumped up like this jumped up five
wrongs I don't feel that way unless I'm
doing the works and having like a sundae
with some walnuts some sprinkles and
Cherry maybe a little caramel sauce in
there I hate walnuts unless I'm doing
something like that I ne I would never
go for the Hershey I just it it
dominates the ice cream and it's it's it
just makes it taste like Hershey's
Chocolate Syrup unless I'm going for the
works if if I'm going for ice cream and
you tell me you could take one only one
thing the like the the whipped cream or
the chocolate syrup on the ice cream 10
out of 10 I'm going whipped cream on on
my ice cream I also think whipped cream
I mean I put whipped cream on my ice
cream you put whipped cream on pies you
could put whipped cream in your in your
hot chocolate on your hot chocolate too
uh whipped cream see I don't like that
though I love that I mean more than
marshmallows I think it starts no no I
think I think when you put the whipped
cream on hot chocolate it starts it
almost it almost looks
you get that light cold cream that hits
your lips first and then the hot
chocolate comes running in after it and
it melts the whipped cream at the exact
same time and it makes the whole thing a
little more creamy maybe you lose some
but you still have that little oh I love
it I love taking a spoon and spooning my
hot chocolate out with a little bit of
whipped cream on each spoon and eating
it that way
everything I find that this is like the
root beer float argument I find that
whipped cream and hot chocolate it just
it's like you got 30 seconds and then
this is going to turn into a disaster
it's good it's melting it's like I
wouldn't call it a disaster you're just
getting more cream in here I gotta tell
you too as a guy with OCD and who's a
little bit of a neat freak and I know we
all think it's cute I hate whipped cream
nose
that's one of the reasons I hate whipped
cream is like when you're trying to sip
it you get the [__] on your nose I can't
stand that that is a very very minor it
happens infraction it happens
whipped cream is it's also I love how it
comes out in that shape
by the way you can make you can put a
bunch of them or you can put one big one
and you could spin it by the way it's
more fun you can make it really high
because it's light chocolate syrup
what can you do with that
so you can only just drizzle it on the
hell of a component in hot chocolate
I'll tell you that you heat up real milk
and and you people whipped cream on cake
I'll tell you what we did as kids
sometimes I just put whipped cream in a
cup and that was my whole dessert
whipped cream in a cup with a spoon I
love it love okay what yeah whipped
cream in a cup what's a spoon I just
eaten the cream nothing snack are you
insane it's great and I'll tell you
nothing no it's not it's not great in
moderation because two tablespoons is a
serving and I think it's like five
calories I don't think there's any sugar
in there there might be a gram of fat
but it's like you can eat that it's like
a keto thing or whatever it's it
satiates your need for sweets like
sometimes when I'm like I want something
sweet but I want you to hold dessert
I'll go in there I'll hit myself with a
with a nice shot of whipped cream I'll
let it dissolve slowly and then I'm like
I feel like I had what I needed so I
think it's also a benefit having it in
the house
you never see someone put on whipped
cream and not go back for more whipped
cream after that well I'll tell you
something right now I'll tell you what I
see drizzled on top of whipped cream a
lot chocolate syrup yeah I see and to me
the metaphor of that is it's it's the
top chocolate syrup it's it's it's the
top it's the last component it's like
this is not done cherry on top fine but
this is not done until the chocolate's
here look every look at all those the
the flavor syrup which a lot of times
Starbucks might do me in with it I mean
they're they're pumping out diabetes for
seven dollars per 12 ounce I mean I
didn't think of people being like Oh my
frappy happy I mean star Starbucks it is
wild what Starbucks is doing they are
taking an Italian tradition of coffee
and espresso
they load that [__] up I mean they
scored it inside the liner of the cup
the sugar on top everything it's it's
like they they're more
uh uh like a con like a like an ice
cream like a a treats company now than
they are a coffee company I remember
Chris Hardwick I was doing at midnight
once
and it was one of the many controversies
surrounding Starbucks where at this time
it was the Republicans boycotting them
for something okay no they didn't say
they wanted to say happy holiday one of
those things okay both the left and the
right have boycotted Starbucks at
separate times which is so funny but on
this one it was the right was Boy
guarding them and I remember Chris
Hardwick saying I am not giving up
Starbucks Starbucks it's all I have left
I quit drinking I don't do drugs anymore
and I remember thinking oh that's if I
ever quit drinking like I have Starbucks
to look forward
crazy milkshake coffees that they make I
think I avoid them at all costs now
because I'm like I'm putting enough bad
[__] in my system I mean whipped cream
is on all of them too so NC whipped
cream is the least the the least
offender but I've watched I've watched
friends but here's the thing and this is
my point about whipped cream I've wa and
and it's the it's it I'm gonna use
Starbucks as an example but it's the
Heat versus the cream it's my point
even when it's cold I've watched this
habit I've watched many a friend get
these Contraption concoctions at
Starbucks that whipped cream looks so
good for five seconds and then it it's
so gross looking it breaks down and it
just it's like it looks like curdled
milk to me after a couple minutes it
doesn't taste like that gross dude it
doesn't taste like that but it's but
that's that goes a long way for me how
unappetizing it now I will say both of
these are sexual
Foods whipped cream is gonna win in the
sex department but chocolate syrup is a
sex food right yeah I mean anything
could be a sex food if you believe
Lobster
I've seen it hot butter I've seen it
yeah hot butter hot sex on the platter
hot sex on a
Lobster platter chocolate syrup doesn't
taste like she used to whipped cream I
could eat it does I could sit I need a
bowl that's that's when's the last time
you had it when's the last time you had
a shot of Hershey's Chocolate Syrup a
shot yeah like like I don't mean like a
shot of it I just mean like when's the
last time you had it uh
I mean I don't know like I'm sure I had
in the last two years or so you know I'm
not I'm not like I'm not like heavy on
sweets but like you know I've had it I
have a problem with chocolate syrup in
that it tastes
it it's the least chocolate thing in the
world that tastes like chocolate it
tastes like chocolate some component of
it but I think out of everything that
has chocolate in it something about
chocolate syrup
lose it it loses some chocolate in there
somewhere it tastes like sweet and it
doesn't really like you don't get that
like if you let's say you had a slice a
chocolate cake you know or a you know a
chocolate chip cookie you know you're
not getting it's not the same it's like
this weird it tastes like syrup as much
as it tastes like chocolate if that
makes any sense whatsoever no I get that
but I think because it's a it's a it's
an it's an elevated and that elevated
it's a it's a version of a thing yeah I
think it is I think that's part of why
it's good I think it's a you know if
it's just typical applications but if it
tasted just if it all it tasted like was
you melted a Hershey bar in a pot
that wouldn't be the same there is a
maple leaf after taste component to it
yes and I like that about it I that that
I don't love about it was also used as
an ailment to treat ailments at one
point read it uh that's cocoa man that's
Coco 1890s chocolate syrup marketed as a
treatment for ailments including for
infant suffering from colic
uh part in part due to the passage of
the 1986 Pure Food and Drug Act which
required clear and accurate labeling
chocolates here began to transition from
primarily medical application to
commercial use
chocolates here was often used in black
and white movies to simulate blood yes
yes psycho the shower scene in Psycho
thank you pimp that is chocolate syrup
that is this is Iconic baby this is a
Hitchcock this is a the Hitchcock movie
the scene in the Hitchcock movie
chocolate syrup yeah but that's we're
arguing taste I know but still it's
pretty cool all right it's pretty cool
uh it's pretty cool the only the only I
mean you know what kind of movies
they're seeing whipped cream in
you know you got to put it like you got
to put a quarter in to watch it for
three minutes you know what I'm saying
okay is it like a Nickelodeon yeah you
might want to call it that
I used to find them in Times Square
uh I I just feel like they're being
drunk with Jim Jefferies in in one of
those Times Square places did you really
go in when he was single this is years
years and years and years ago we were
shit-faced in one of those Times Square
places and he just kept going
made I could have a wank in there and I
was like yes and he kept going he was so
drunk it wasn't registering and he kept
going I can go in there I can wank and I
kept going yes and it got to a point
where I was screaming at him and I was
like you can go have a way is that
supposed to is that is that an Unwritten
rule
no that's what they were made for I
don't know who would set foot in that
legally step foot in or set foot in
set foot
I think it could be both to tell you the
truth
set foot right that's what I always
thought but I think it could be both
well of course it could be both but the
term is set foot right yeah how the
would anyone walk into one of those
oh wow
wow participated I mean we just shot
something for television something yeah
oh we were we were in good die Spirits
we're all drinking that was the night I
met Ari for the first time get out we
met him at a wanking Booth no we shot a
thing for HBO and already took his pants
down and exposed himself on HBO and that
and he was like the talk of the whole
production what was that what was on HBO
we shot a show that Jim Norton hosted
called down and dirty okay and each
episode was three unknown comics and
then a headliner and on my episode Jim
Jeffries was I don't I think they
re-edited it and and it it didn't air
like this but the episode I shot they
shot two episodes that night one of the
headliners was Dice and one was Jim
Jefferies and then me Ari
uh
Jim Norton hosted it Lemmy from
Motorhead was the DJ like he was like
the Kid Capri okay like but it was
Norton so he played all metal
it was awesome it was a we had a blast
we had the best time this was happening
inside a Times Square no no the show was
shot in Jersey and then we all went into
Manhattan because they had an after
party I think they had an I think they
threw the rap party at a strip club like
as a kitschy fun like okay get it it was
a dirty comedy show and we got
shit-faced at the strip club and then
you know who's in there we were all in
the mood
who's in there
well the one we went to was strippers
where the a thing would go up no way
yeah it was like the old school one like
like in the cartoon like in the red
light district yeah it was like old
school what I think cartoon was like
right like and they talked to you
through a little intercom no they don't
yeah
yeah so they watch you wild
yeah if you choose to do that I guess I
can't remember if Jim actually went in
or not I think he was just mesmerized by
the idea that you could I feel like he
probably did you're trying to do what
you can do it's okay
trying to reel it back in I also don't
think he would care at all did I say Jim
Jefferies I met Jeffrey Jim Jim Jeff
Jimmy's
you you know who you meant model Ronald
yeah Donald McDonald
um uh hey by the way what does take it
up with
what is it Bloom Cafe what does that
mean why does everybody write down
where'd it come from is that a hey babe
joke yeah okay Chris just frequency
place for the food in Staten Island and
you guys just started screaming it well
I I don't know I don't know how it came
to be but we told everyone to if they
have any issue large or small or like
anything at all go on to
go on to
this guy
being chocolate syrup is baffling to me
as a fat slob
calling himself up yeah how you can take
something as good as chocolate bar and
transform it into a disgusting mess of a
dessert it's basically a tragedy you can
buy he wins that's awesome Pedro wins
follow Pedro at Carr car caravello which
is both
c-a-r-a-v-e-l-o-o the letter P
30672 follow him God that's so funny uh
see I I agree whipped cream enhances
more dishes can you roll the enhances
more dishes far more versatile from
fruit fruity to Sweet Cakes to pies
pudding to Jello didn't even go there
with that yet the clear winner I was
gonna I was saying this before forgot
about Jello and especially I forgot
about Jello damn yeah I mean I tell me
right now how many applications do you
have for chocolate syrup there's not a
ton where you're not putting it on Jello
you're not putting it on pudding
um but I I have seen it used on cakes uh
you know on pies syrup on a cake yeah if
you especially if you go into a diner
and you look in that little rotating on
a pie with like a banana cream pie yeah
but also too like those like you see
like okay where there's a white icing I
see a lot of chocolate chocolate syrup
drizzle on that you know what I mean
okay uh but I mean look the main thing
is ice cream and chocolate milk but
you're batting you're batting a thousand
with like with chocolate milk I mean
it's like
you have two big things but whipped
cream is so so much that's very funny
the show made me so much more the show
made so much more sense when I realized
Sal and Joe were a couple
uh go ahead finish your chocolate syrup
and vanilla ice cream is the sexiest
dessert I do oh I know Maddie hi Maddie
I agree Maddie it is sexy there is
something sexy about it and I'm not even
a big vanilla ice cream guy as we all
know but there is something very sexy
about the Stark whiteness of that ice
cream with the chocolate syrup drizzled
over it nah bro yeah if I'm having ice
cream whipped cream a big pile of
whipped cream on top and and distribute
the whipped cream with the ice cream
bites is the only way to go can I also
say whipped cream can create a tasty
bikini yes chocolate syrup looks like
someone couldn't make it to the bathroom
in time all right that's fair this show
is sponsored by better help
uh I like better help quite a bit I use
better help quite a bit
um here's the thing people sometimes you
hit a point in life
where
maybe you feel for example that you're
uncertain about where you're headed or
where you're going what the right path
is for you
and even
choosing how that what that path is
getting to that point of figuring out
what the right path is I've been in this
place many times and this is just one
example of the things we go through one
of the trials and tribulations that we
face in life
uh and better help in particular has
helped me with this specific thing uh
but they're there to help you with all
of it whether you're dealing with
decisions about your career or
relationships or anything else therapy
can really help you stay connected to
what you really want while you navigate
your life so you can move forward with
confidence with excitement security uh
better help truly truly has made a big
difference in my life and I I just can't
recommend it enough uh if you are also
someone who in the past has benefited
from therapy uh I think and you're
looking to do it again I think that
better help is a great way to pursue
that I am one of those people therapy
throughout my life and especially now
with using betterhelp has helped me
get the Clutter out
pinpoint problems I need to solve
pinpoint ways for me to solve them and
again
figuring out that right path to move
forward with the right feelings the
right confidence the appropriate amount
of excitement
I I just think it's great let therapy be
your map with better help visit
betterhelp.com tastebuds and you're
going to get 10 off your first month
that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com slash taste buds
here hello it's fresh hello fresh
America's number one meal kit I'm loving
what hellofresh does take a bite out of
the summer with hello fresh from Chef
crafted seasonal recipes to their new
fresh and fit summer menu hellofresh
brings you the flavor right to your door
these are meal kits that come in they're
affordable they're easy to make you're
getting things cooked quickly so you can
have the meal that is satisfying that
you deserve to have you're not having to
go eat a bunch of junk because you're in
a hurry you're not having to spend time
out of your precious day in the
supermarket and you're not especially
this is the most important to me
spending a ton of money to eat quality
food
hello fresh is helping you do all of
this in your house affordable convenient
quick quality all of that in your home
delivered right to your door uh you're
gonna get what you want with hello fresh
uh and it's it's not just the same old
thing all the time they offer 40 recipes
to choose from every single week so
you'll never get bored and I think
that's important when you're trying to
eat right and you want to eat well you
you don't want to get bored that's going
to be a problem hellofresh is solving
that problem too when you need dinner
fast don't call for delivery think
hellofresh they're Fast and Fresh
recipes are ready in just 15 minutes or
less that's amazing
plus hellofresh 25 cheaper than takeout
again it's America's number one meal kit
I use hellofresh I enjoy hello fresh I'm
somebody who likes to cook but I'm
somebody that always doesn't have the
time to indulge in a very long laborious
cooking process uh and and hello fresh
has served me well on the nights where I
want to make something for myself and I
want to get it done quickly without
sacrificing quality or spending money on
that wasteful delivery anyway go to
hellofresh.com tastebuds50 use code
tastebuds50 you're gonna get 50 off plus
free shipping again go to hellofresh.com
tastebuds50 and use code tastebuds50 for
50 off plus free shipping folks Joe
DeRose here from the taste buds podcast
I got live shows coming up and you're
going to get all the info and tickets
for those live shows at joederrosa.com
where am I going to be September 16th
Avenal New Jersey at the Avenal
Performing Arts Center September 21st
and 22nd Toronto in Canada at the JFL
just for laughs Festival in Toronto Las
Vegas Nevada September 24 29th through
October 1st at skank Fest and then the
big one Philadelphia PA November 11th
theater of the Living Arts that's the
big Hometown show again get your tickets
at joederrosa.com all right and if you
need more of me as you wait with baited
breath to see me live doing I Never
Promised You a Rose Garden you can head
now to wherever you get digital music to
hear my new record the penthouse paper
selected readings it's me reading all
the op-eds I did for Penthouse magazine
for a few years none of the Rose Garden
material but a whole bunch of other
material that's where the special thing
records again wherever you get your
digital music it's available now and
last but not least if you're in New York
City come see us at Joey roses have a
sandwich have a drink joeyrosesnyc.com
hello guys and I just want to give you
some dates right now the very last
weekend of the Joker's tour for now the
first leg is happening July 27th uh 28th
and 29th we're at Nashville at the Grand
Ole Opry game Bridge field house uh in
Indianapolis and the stifle theater for
two shows on the 29th in St Louis those
are available at
impracticaljokerslive.com come the New
Year we will be adding the second leg of
this tour so if you didn't see us yet
don't fret uh other than that the reason
we are shifting is because I am going
back on the second leg of my solo tour
and I am filming a special in December
at the Vic Theater in Chicago Chicago
and Chicago's surrounding greater
metropolitan area I chose you come out
and support your boy
um leading up to that I will be at the
Hartford Funny Bone in August I will be
at the Syracuse Funny Bone in September
I will be at the there was another Funny
Bone in there and I don't remember uh
Albany the Albany Funny Bone in August
as well and then we're doing Bowling
Green Kentucky Cincinnati Ohio Toledo uh
Wilkes bar bear I never know guys I'm
sorry in Pennsylvania Wilmington
Delaware uh Macon Georgia Savannah
Georgia Athens Georgia Peoria Illinois
Rockford Illinois Cedar Rapids Iowa
Springfield Illinois and then I'm doing
a very special one-night warm-up show
right before the special in Elkhart
Indiana at the Lerner Theater those
tickets if not yet are going to be on
sale very soon at savocano comedy.com
pay attention to my socials because I'm
going to Tweet all the pre-sale stuff to
get the best tickets first uh that's
pretty much it check out my merch and
check out the podcast merch go to
samplecanocomedy.com uh Jokers are
starting up again season 10 the second
half of that Thursday nights at 10 on
TBS and True TV I love you I will see
you on the road I'm very excited
but I will say this
let's talk about the delivery system
ever done whippets with chocolate syrup
I knew people were going to say whippets
I said that the pimp earlier but here's
the thing
let's start with the delivery system
chocolate syrups in a squeeze bottle
you go
there's a classiness to it there's a
technique to It Whatever whipped cream
with that whipped cream whipped cream
let's just grow that only adds to it
that only adds to it and what's great is
it's liquid inside the can but then
Through Chemistry it comes out as a
light fluffy delectable treat I love
that they also put the like the the
plastic like they made it a star shape
so when it comes out you feel you feel
like a pastry chef when you put whipped
cream on something I feel you feel like
a pastry it also is great for decorating
I feel like it is the you can't decorate
with chocolate I feel like that whipped
cream canned to pastry chefs is what the
microwave oven is to regular Cooks like
I I like I feel like it is such a feel
like that though like you feel like the
can everything wrong with America you
feel like you're what's the thing you
squeeze them do you put the icing in
it's a
you know an icing dispenser no you know
what I'm saying no I no I know I'm I
don't know I know what you mean though
it's you feel like it's it's got It's
it's an air of that kind of thing I see
I could spell words you can make smiley
faces you can't do anything delicate
with a whipped cream dispense you're not
doing anything you can't the whipped
cream comes out in such a it's like it's
like an Arctic Rush blowing the whipped
cream can and the the technology and the
way that it comes out might be the most
fun delivery device for a food let alone
a a treat fun sure but fun in a
exploding water balloon kind of way it
has no Grace it has no Grace and aren't
aerosols bad for the environment thank
you and also there's something in that
can that can get you I think they did
something there's something no I think
they so I think they dealt with it
there's an element in that can that can
get you so high I've done a lot of
weapons in my day
that you see plaid
I'm not exaggerating right now whippets
put you on another planet bro I did I
did with this good or bad well it's fun
as hell but it's not good for you oh
I've never done it I'm telling you I did
whip-its once and I closed my eyes when
I came around to the bottle
no no you hold no you hold no I'm gonna
tell you I think you got to get it all
out until it's at the end no I'm gonna
tell you how to do it okay no in fact
you shouldn't do that because you're
using too much of the CO2 what you have
to do is is that CO2 that's coming out
yes
yeah dude so when you suck it on the end
yeah it's hard to get blasted with CO2
yeah it's bad for you so but here's what
here's how you do a whip it with it
here's how you do a whip it with it you
take it do not try this at home
do not try this at home I'm not
condoning this here's what you do kids
come on down to Joy roses yeah you take
it you take the can and you need to do
it with a full can
and you you you tip the thing so air is
coming out but no cream is coming out
and you there's a sweet spot yeah you
inhale yeah you inhale that's a Whip-It
it's a very weak form of a whip it but
it is a whip it it will work and then
are you then you are you then wasting
are you doing old cans useless
afterwards so you are suck sucking in
CO2
yes that's what a whip it is it's just a
shot of CO2 which is poison yes into
your lungs yes
and it's bad for you too because you can
freeze like if you like CO2 can like
freeze your lungs which it's bad dude
this is what your dispensary system is
it's it's the problem they point out is
that N2 o is nearly 300 times more
powerful at warming the climate than CO2
so the n2o release from whipped cream is
equivalent to about 31
000 tons of CO2 how's that possible if
they mean like with yearly like a yearly
that's not from one can
this equals the energy use of an average
house for 2 385 years what are we
talking about here I don't understand
what we're talking about here it's bad
how would it even be legal
well a lot of things that are bad for
the environment are legal I mean that's
not an argument but what they're saying
here is
what I would love to know what the ratio
is they're saying there
my point is whether it's horrible or not
it's bad and there's no problem with
chocolate syrup nothing nice
click on that why was whipped cream
banned sorry
though candle cream does contain nitrous
oxide that's what it is it's not CO2
well nitrous oxide is coming out of the
CO2 canister right but you're not
breathing in CO2 you're nitrous okay
nitrous yeah okay sorry wait the hand
was only intended for the replaceable no
what are they talking about charger
cartridges okay which are sold
independently of the dessert topic I
don't know what we're talking about
anymore well it's just it's are New
Yorkers getting carded to buy whipped
cream
um
Turkey Hill when I was in college and
one night me and my friend Pat literally
went Acro Pat stevening the example my
rap partner Pat we went across the
street four times and bought every can
of whipped cream off the shelf from
Turkey we cleared out Turkey Hill to
keep doing whippets
and we wasted that's what happened about
20 cans of whipped cream
roughly
oh not wait I mean it depends all that
fun whipped cream just down the drain oh
I mean the whippets weren't a bad time
I don't know man I I just feel like
chocolate syrup is uh
it's got nothing really to offer outside
of those two things I I I I I hear you
that there are more uses for whipped
cream like chocolate more people I bet
you more people buy whipped cream
chocolate syrup to me creates two King
uh uh substances which is chocolate milk
and then an such an elevated version of
ice cream it takes ice cream to such
another level whereas whipped cream adds
a fun fluffy I'll give you a magic show
Magic Shell takes it to another level
yeah I mean I'm not going to bring that
in that's technically chocolate syrup
hot fudge
hot fudge I would say
look I'd say they're all technically
chocolate syrup I'm not going to bring
them someone says they want a hot fudge
sundae can you achieve that by putting
in squeezing in chocolate syrup okay no
hot fudge is its own thing that's why
that's why if you notice when you eat a
hot fudge when you eat a true hot fudge
sundae there's almost like there's oh
it's like so there's also there's almost
like chunks in it I love that that's on
fudge right there yeah McDonald's
I know it's not I never said it was I
think people are gonna uh uh are gonna
conflate the time I don't think so I'm
seeing a lot of chocolate syrup makes
Milk but I'm not seeing a lot there's
definitely no whipped cream in on the
McDonald's menu
there's none I'm looking at one right
there you have a picture up of it right
now no no that's not whipped cream
whipped cream yeah okay
well
and again I don't even know what is that
thing is that a McFlurry no that's not a
McFlurry what the hell is that Berry
thing I don't know I can't believe we
just talked about me by the way how did
we how do we how have we not tried the
Grimace happy birthday meal yet oh yeah
what is it I don't know what is it it's
a Grimace shake that a word on the
street is tastes like crunch berries
that can't be good for you uh a Big Mac
or Grimace oh my God
I need it wait what's wait what's 1490
calories the meal
the full meal dude it's a it's a cup of
ice cream that's purple
fries in a Big Mac that's 14.99 yeah I'm
not shocked by that medium fries medium
shake and a Big Mac 1500 calories
I want to taste the Grimace Shake even
though it's going to set off my milk
allergy
uh I gotta taste it right look how good
that looks look at the whipped cream in
that photo look at it it looks like
nothing like that when you receive it's
like a beautiful untouched Snowy
Mountain yeah do you think that's how
it's gonna it looks gorgeous look at
those ribbons of cream Sal this is like
unreal this is like saying look at the
Big Mac in that photo it's like no but
there's gonna be a difference as a
layperson I could make that that the top
of that with just the can and my arms
you I I would like to put that to it it
looks like a cloud I would like to put
that to a test I think you are giving
the uh uh artistic ability uh that a
whipped cream can allows far too much
credit I I have tried to get a little
Fancy with a whipped cream can and like
you know where I mean you go right up I
feel like you hit that thing and it is
pedal to the metal that [__] is shooting
out man no you could actually press
lighter and it comes out softer and
slower you don't know about that you
know about the pressure on it I'm
thinking of ready whip cans so maybe
maybe there's a better camera too you
just push it just a little bit I'm
telling you dude I have ready whip in my
house at all times show me pimp look up
show me ready whip look up ready whip
video
I want to see like a guy getting down
with with some ready whip I want to see
like somebody yeah that one that's
perfect I want to see how he does oh
look at that he's just using it to
decorate he's doing little dollops all
along the side look at that a young kid
I was gonna say that doesn't hurt my
argument to the three year old was just
that see how that just came out that's
how it comes out every time if you're
pushing it all the way sure
it's great it's so much fun are you
kidding me it's like a national it's
like you're painting the slice of pie
it's so much fun it's so much fun
there's a national shortage of ready
whip God this country is finished Jesus
God
what about ready Nene oh yeah look at
that oh look at that alcohol whipped
cream so you shoot it in your mouth and
it's a shot
that's pretty cool it's probably
literally nothing in each squirt but
where are we at bespoke post sending you
that box of Awesome every month uh I get
a box of Awesome from bespoke post every
single month and I've gotten such cool
stuff
uh if you don't know and or you're not
familiar which you probably are by now
because they've sponsored us for a while
uh but if you're not bespoke post is
taking very cool items they're curating
very cool cool items from small Artisan
companies uh newer companies making very
very unique things uh uh and not
necessarily just newer companies but
just you you get what I'm saying smaller
Artisan truly uh you know the
mom-and-pop type of thing which I'm
really into but they're going to these
companies they're getting these cool
items they're curating them they're
putting them into a box they're sending
them to you every month uh each box is
valued at seventy dollars but you're
only paying a fraction of that price I
just got really amazing uh whiskey
glasses uh the uh and and very very cool
leather coasters and you never know
what's going to show up but I gotta tell
you and I'm not just saying this
anything that shows up I am excited that
I have it and it's usable it's useful
you know sometimes people get a little
freaked out by by a let's call it a
mystery box showing up every month
that's not what this is this is quality
Goods that you can get a lot of use out
of and
it's a surprise and that surprise is a
treat okay that's that's the way to look
at this because that's what it is ninety
percent of everything that comes in your
box of awesome is from small up and
coming Brands uh you're gonna get 20 off
your first monthly box when you sign up
at box of awesome.com it's free to sign
up and you can skip a month or cancel at
any time twenty percent off
your first monthly box when you set up a
box of awesome.com and you got to enter
promo code taste buds at checkout that's
important again box of awesome.com use
promo code taste buds to check out for
twenty percent off your first box box of
awesome.com promo code taste buds folks
it's game time game time uh I don't know
about you but I'm somebody that likes to
go to events and I like to go or decide
if I'm going at the last minute uh I
find that with my schedule and with many
of your schedules as well it's real hard
to plan something months or weeks even
in advance it's hard to set aside that
time and know that you're going to be
able to attend to this thing when it
comes up that's where I like game time
why game time is helping you get last
minute deals on the best available
tickets Flash Deals and last minute
tickets easy to find and buy tickets for
every kind of event in your area through
game time no matter what type of event
it is they're showing you images of seat
views you you know what you're going to
see when you sit down and it is the
lowest price guaranteed there's event
cancellation protection there's job
launch protection it's just a great
service I like it it's making it easy to
get those tickets and taking the stress
out of buying the tickets so you can
focus on the fun of the event itself
forget about planning months in advance
game time has deals on tickets right now
up to the day of the event
all right and again you're going to get
exclusive Flash Deals on tickets for
football basketball baseball concerts
comedy theater and much much more
it's the fastest growing ticket app in
the country for a reason all right so
here's the thing snag tickets without
the stress with Game Time download the
game time app create an account use
promo code taste buds for twenty dollars
off your first purchase terms do apply
again create an account and redeem code
taste buds for twenty dollars off your
first purchase download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed
there's probably barely I want to read
some of the phones here though
there was bad whipped cream but there
was no bad chocolate syrup disagree hard
disagree well what is the bad by the way
buddy you got ready whip I got Hershey's
forget it game I got Nestle Quick game
over I got Bosco game dude I just named
three Titans in the chocolate syrup game
three Titans you know you got one you
got ready with no no no but there's a
ready whip equivalent a hundred times
over give me some other do they want
household names no no they're not but
it's but that's all I want but there's
the exact same conceit and they are
slight variations of each other and it's
great because I actually taste when I
get my like when I get like the can from
Trader Joe's not even the Trader Joe's
brand it's like a pink can and there's
another one when I get those I'm in for
a different taste than ready but I don't
even I'm saying that that's I'm not
arguing that I'm not arguing that's not
what I'm saying we're saying two
different things oh have you ever heard
of but hold on I am saying I my food
that I'm defending has three brands that
are Trix rabbit Nestle Quick rabbit like
iconic Bosco Nestle Quick syrup
Hershey's here like you've got ready
with ready whip is Iconic but that's it
it ends it ends there with whipped cream
I'm seeing a lot of whipped creams here
did you but they're not like do you ever
have flavor do you ever have the
chocolate whipped cream amazing never
once at a peanut butter whipped cream
never below your two bowls off I don't
agree okay do you have the peppermint
whipped cream I wouldn't eat it I know I
hate peppermint and peppermint with
cream is gross to me I'm telling you
listen I'm not saying the other one
whipped cream palette because there's a
there's a there's a flavor out there
that's waiting that's waiting I will
tell you this if whipped cream if I had
a flavored one it might change my mind
because that's been my biggest issue
with whipped cream is there's not really
a flavor it just tastes like sugar to me
it tastes like sugar yeah Hershey's
there come on you got Cool Whip right
there you got Reese's does one right
there that's the one I get to that tat
that that pink one on the one end on the
left there you get that I mean look at
that Reese's one can you imagine the
chemical concentration in that I've had
that too it's excellent all right I'm
sure it tastes great I'm just saying
you know I think you have to rethink
eating whipped cream is like shipping
the bubbly parts of a Coke there's no
substance
but man do your taste buds thank you for
it chocolate milk would be gone forever
I can't imagine a world without
chocolate milk I agree chocolate syrup
is honestly nasty come on no it's not
putting on putting on the whipped cream
bra was the only way to get my uncle to
notice me
can't get high off chocolate syrup
chocolate syrup can be messy and it
makes it makes it look like I ate
literal [__] I mean I guess yeah he he
someone said it should have been ready
with a Cool Whip I just I think we might
have I think we might have argued that
within a with an episode once before but
I think it's just too close to each
other to to Really extract it and you
you know as well as I do that ain't no
argument Cool Whip Cool Whip is the
Rolls-Royce no no no of whipped cream
right cool whip would lose to ready whip
Cool Whip is Cool Whip Cool Whip when I
first had Cool Whip I was like oh my God
this is what I always wanted whipped
cream to be cool whip is the Miracle
Whip to the Hellman's Mayo that's what
that is dare you you know it is I might
go get some Cool Whip too you know it is
I haven't had cool cool whip is whipped
cream man
it's so much more but it's it's whipped
cream you understand that it's so much
more it's whipped cream
I hate whipped cream I love Cool Whip
let me tell you what Cool Whip is
Paul Mooney the comedian used to get on
stage talking about how much he hated
white people and then he would date
white women
Cool Whip is that white woman
[Laughter]
it's the one that gets through
cream has been around since the 16th
century it was included in recipes that
date back to 1549 first called whipped
cream in
1673. uh yeah I mean it used to be
called milk snow oh that's fun in very
old text it was whip it with a branch
cream only whips at temperatures under
50 degrees that's fun I mean warmer
becomes butter
that's interesting though because now
that explains why sometimes butter have
you ever gotten butter in a restaurant
you're like you're like I thought that
that was sour cream and it was butter
like it looked like cream literal cream
yeah that must be that it's well like
whipped butter whipped butter yeah this
is the tallest dollop of whipped cream
on a mug of hot chocolate this is the
Guinness Book of World Records for the
tallest dollop of whipped cream on a mug
of hot chocolate man they're really
getting specific with these records
yeah that's that's kind of a like I can
train for this that's not even yeah
that's not even I want to beat this
record this isn't even one
you couldn't even brag about this at a
party this one Cole Guinness
wait where was the
holy [__] is that real go back one
second look at that ice cream cone wait
wait we got the video finally playing I
want to see this
I could do that
wait that's it
this is Guinness Guinness has something
to do with us wait that's it
by the way you know what I've never done
by the way hold on it keeps falling over
and he just keeps going of course
eventually it's going to poly pile up I
mean I wish I can get my mouth right
under that but do you see what I'm
saying he's not doing it I don't really
know what's going on here he's just
squirting whipped cream until it piles
up high enough that it's considered I'll
tell you something set your word that's
bull that's being stupid I'll tell you
one thing though that's something I
never did I never just emptied out a
whipped cream bottle from from open just
open it and empty the whole thing out
and just see what it yields that when
I'm feeling Wild next I'm gonna do that
big Friday night for you when I'm
feeling one all right all right you know
listen I'm gonna get like a some people
say you need to slowly get yourself into
trouble but I'm gonna get a crock pot
I'm gonna empty up I bet you it won't
even come close to filling the crock pot
yes it will you think so the tall
well what size can I'm saying so
standard can I think that I think well I
I picture a big salad bowl is this a
thing
people are doing it on The Today Show
was it like a viral trend
my point it looks like so much fun and
it looks so delicious tell me tell me
I'm wrong that looks so delicious it
looks it look here's the thing what
about a pie in the face what about a pie
in the face you're not doing that
without whipped cream it looks delicious
and then you taste it and you go this
tastes like sugar air there's nothing to
it like there's just a cream it doesn't
really though you're gonna miss out on
years I mean years centuries of Comedy
uh let's go to the phones one last time
I have a question for Joe what would you
rather whipped cream or cotton candy
cotton candy a thousand percent and I
know cotton candy is literally sugar air
but cotton candy cotton candy ever in a
million years cotton candy is the most
overrated thing no dude cotton candy at
a Fairgrounds I mean it's just come on
you have it once you're like I'm good
for 20 years all right but that wasn't a
question what would you rather eat with
whipped cream of cotton candy whipped
cream 100 to 100 times out of 100 let's
be honest both of these combined on a
spouse you're having a hell of a night
why just a spouse why can't it just be
somebody I'm casually seeing we have
cream is a celebration chocolates here
but for the Sunday night depression
feelings
chocolate syrup doesn't melt whipped
cream turns into a weird milky substance
after five minutes thank you Meg it's
crazy
substance no but because it's chemical
ridden and and shot out of a can it gets
weird I'm telling you it's gross use
real chocolate for chocolate and whipped
cream on top of everything I think
that's strike again that's part of her
point that she said the can of whipped
cream is an explosive in the wrong
situation that is that could be I guess
it's content Under Pressure but also
chocolate will kill your dog
uh we already used that argument quit on
another episode I [__] hate whip
sorry beep it hate whipped cream it's so
deceptive and it's taste and texture
thank you yes
if you get a little whipped cream on you
it's no big deal if you get chocolate on
you looks like you [__] yourself that's
a dumb joke but it is true I will give
you that whipped cream on you you wipe
it right off chocolate on you you got to
change your shirt Cool Whip in the
freezer yes I have
low calorie ice cream now so people are
yes I agree with that about Frozen Cool
Whip I might have to go get some Cool
Whip tonight
I can't stop thinking about it now about
Cool Whip I mean we mentioned it 100
seconds yeah you've been thinking it for
the whole time no I'm just saying I
can't stop thinking about going to get
cool so you're gonna go get whipped
cream tonight Cool Whip whipped cream
Cool Whip what is Cool Whip
it's just better what is it
It's a Wonderful substance in a tub that
comes in the freezer section is how they
marketed a substance in the tub uh
that's how they Market it as
whipped cream I don't think it says
whipped cream on the canister or on the
tub first of all it comes in a tub
unlike your weird wedding whip that sits
on a shelf in warm weather and it's fine
100 needs to be refrigerated ready whip
yeah you don't buy refrigerators yes you
do no you do not yes you do Joe trust me
Whipped I've worked in a convenience
store and I bought reddi whip for my
whole life whipped topping Cool Whip is
a whipped topic what's whipped what is
it that's whipped I just said it doesn't
say whipped cream you go I said it
didn't say whipped cream on the tub and
it doesn't say whipped cream on top that
was what I said
uh you buy Cool Whip wait Cool Whip It
is a is an American brand imitation
whipped cream so it's not whipped cream
it's a whipped topping
it's not whipped cream there's something
look it's fake it's non-dairy I love it
man
it tastes weird oh stop it Sal cool
weird
look it's a whipped cream it's on my
side I just think it does you gotta you
gotta people either really like what uh
Cool Whip or they don't at all like it's
got It's got some taste that's very its
own and it's not for everybody cream
whip all right we gotta go we gotta go
to Humble Pie pimp let's do it let's
close this out this was a very pleasant
episode with you today thank you no
problem guys check out our merch you can
get our merch on our websites you can go
to savocano comedy.com or Georgia
rosainfo.com no just jodarosa.com oh I
got it I got it I got it let's do it I
found the guy that had it and what
happened and I bought it but how much uh
I'll tell you all fair but not much you
bought it because of you
no he bought it because it was named
that was his name and he bought it to
like house like wedding photos or
something and he was like he's like I'm
not gonna be shitty like give me this
much and it's fine okay and yeah yeah
it's nice yeah or you can go to the no
pressure website and get some merch
7 300 votes pimp again choosing
chocolate chip going against me yes all
right it wasn't a blowout
it wasn't a trouncing and it was a much
needed win I know man especially from La
like the last time I thought I was going
to take that whipped cream
57.9 for the win versus chocolate syrup
at 42.1
all right after seven seven thousand
three hundred votes I still love you
babe love you too taste buds they coming
to the mic talking about the food they
hate talking about the food they like
two Fool's gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to them